Vermont senator Bernie Sanders is urging
Democrats to address immigration when
they take control of the house next year
Sanders who was just reacting as a
political independent is pushing a bold
agenda that includes protecting daca
recipients and comprehensive immigration
reform he also wants a $15 minimum wage
new laws to address climate change and a
trillion dollar infrastructure plan the
former presidential candidate spells it
out in his new book where we go from
here two years in the resistance
senator Sanders good morning good
morning good to be with you want to talk
to you about some of the news of the day
tear gas being fired at some of these
migrants trying to cross the border
including women and children seem
choking from the tear gas should border
agents be able to use tear gas and
self-defense well I think you got a
really tragic situation and you're gonna
minimize minimize the level of force
that is being used all of which speaks
to what you just mentioned the need for
us to finally deal with immigration in a
comprehensive way you write in your book
that President Trump is on the wrong
side of decency on this he's on the
wrong side of history and the wrong side
of decency right now in this country yet
some two million young people who were
raised in this country who know the
United States is their only home who are
in the daca program was scared to death
of being deported they're in the
military they're in school they are
working that's one Rhodes Scholar that's
God that's right and you got ten million
people in this country including several
million who are sustaining our
agriculture in this country who are
undocumented the time is long overdue
for Congress and this president to say
we need comprehensive immigration reform
and in my view a path toward citizens so
comprehensive immigration reform did
pass the Senate years ago and now that
the blockage of course was a
republican-controlled house now the
Democrats control the house so how do
you get to YES on this no I think you
will see the house raising this issue
and bringing it up as soon as possible
and I think we got a share a chance to
do something meaningful and what
compromise with Democrats make which
they'd have to to pass on it I don't
know that we have the time to get into
all of the details but the good news is
that I think Democrats in the house are
serious about comprehensive immigration
reform I think we
some Republicans in the Senate and let's
see if we can do something it's a major
issue but you know the there are other
issues out there as well and what are
the issues that concerns me right now is
that as we talk about Black Friday and
people shopping we should remember that
millions of workers who are out there
now who are selling us products in
department stores on making what I
consider to be starvation wages yeah and
I think we have got to finally make it
clear that if you work 40 hours a week
in America you know what you should not
be poor you should not be living in
poverty that means raising the minimum
wages what the American people want and
you said despite all the issues of
senator Sanders you said really this
country is more United than it appears
you don't believe in red state blue
states it's so hard to feel that we are
united and most things you said we
really are United you know on many areas
we are united and I think the media on
the place that for example you do some
polling dude the American people think
we should raise the minimum wage to a
living wage yes yes the American people
believe that health care is a right and
we should move to Medicare for all yes
the American people believe that they
throw in sense absolutely common-sense
gun safety legislation absolutely the
American people want to pay more in
taxes if we can do away with private
insurance premiums yes let's do they say
no on that just to be fair they want to
pay for all the things that you're well
alright but if I told you if you were a
family of four that was independently
employed or self-employed you're paying
twenty eight thousand dollars a year for
your private health insurance I'd say
hey Nora guess what you're gonna pay ten
thousand more in taxes but not that
twenty eight thousand you know what you
take Bernie where do I sign up and by
the way you want to lower the cost of
prescription drugs in which we are
getting ripped off by the drug and that
is one area where you and the president
are aligned in lowering prescription
drug prices and boosting infrastructure
are these two issues that you'd be
willing to work with the president
absolutely doesn't has talked a lot
about the high cost of prescription
drugs he hasn't done anything on it
we've got to have to take yeah we need
to take on the incredible greed of this
pharmaceutical industry we just put
something on line last week of a young
man in his late 20s who died because he
couldn't afford the insulin that he
needed
for its diabetes people all over this
country are in that position
meanwhile the drug companies make
outrageous profits we got to deal with
that reality Democratic on that note
some in the Democratic Party disagree
with that strategy say that there's
absolutely nothing that the Democratic
Party should align themselves with this
president with is that wrong of course
it's wrong I mean if the president wants
to do the right thing on prescription
drugs and he lies all of the time so we
can be skeptical about it
but if he does of course you want to
work with him we have an infrastructure
today and that's roads bridges water
systems wastewater plants that are in
collapse we can create millions of
good-paying jobs rebuilding our rail
system and our infrastructure should we
do it should we work with them if he
wants to work with us absolutely there's
another issue out there that just came
out in a report from 13 federal agencies
and that is while President Trump
continues to think the climate change is
not real or it's a hoax what his own
agencies are telling him is that if we
don't get our act together you're gonna
see more horrible wildfires like we saw
in California you're gonna see more
droughts which will impact the
production of corn and soybeans you're
gonna see more flooding we have got to
transform our energy system and take on
the fossil fuel industry no question
about it in the Senate how many
Republican colleagues could you have a
conversation with on the climate change
issue that you think you could work on
sometimes this is what I think is
significant when people minimize the
takeover of the house by the Democrats
it's one thing for Republicans to on
their own come forward it's another
thing to get a bill from the house which
says you know what we're going to put
money into wind into solar into
sustainable energy are you gonna vote
against it well maybe I won't maybe it's
not a bad idea so I think that takeover
Democrats in the house now can work with
the Senate in transforming our energy
system telling the fossil fuel industry
that there are short-term profits are
not more important than the future of
this planet for our kids that our
grandsons
senator a lot more we have to talk to
you about hopefully can come back and
sit at the table with us love to do it
what are you talking about 2020 perhaps
for you all right Bernie Sanders and we
know spent getting with right